[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio.
I'm an engineer on
the Google Drive
Developer Relations team.
And this is Gus from
the Google+
Developer Relations team.
Hi Gus.
GUS CLASS: Hey, Claudio.
It's a pleasure to be here.
And it's exciting to be hearing
all about the new
Google+ and Drive integration.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Yeah, exactly.
So today, we're going to talk
about a new feature we just
launched that integrates my
world, Google Drive, with
Gus's world, which is Google+.
So you might have noticed, and
you might have read the
announcement, that now when
you share a document on
Google+, what you see is a nicer
interactive widget that
shows more about the
document itself.
Let me show you what it is like
so it's going to be easy
to talk about it when we
all know about this.
So let's go to my screen.
What I have in front of me is a
presentation that I created
on Google Drive on my account.
It's actually a presentation
that I used to talk about
Google Drive at GDG DevFest.
Maybe some of you were there.
If I want to share this
presentation on Google+, I can
now simply copy the URL, go to
my Google+ page, so go to the
stream, and share something.
I can put the link as
I will put any other
types of link here.
So I put the link there.
What is going to happen is that
Google+ will check what's
at that page, what's behind
that link, and when that
loads, we're going to see
that it gets some
information about the page.
We're going to see
how that works.
And that information is actually
shown in a nice
graphical way.
So let me share this, and
then we'll talk a
bit more about it.
So my new presentation-- and
you can write whatever you
want here, of course.
This is a message that goes
together with the document.
And, well, let me share it to
an empty circle I have, just
not to fill my stream with
useless content.
And then share it.
Now you can see this
new presentation
is here in my stream.
It has a nice play button.
Remember, this is
a presentation.
This is not a video.
So what happens when I click
Play is that the presentation
itself gets loaded.
And now, without leaving
the stream, I can
check all the slides.
So I can go back and forth.
I can see all of them.
I can go full screen.
I can jump to any slides,
and so on.
And if I need to, I can just
click to the Google Docs link
and go back to the Google Docs
page, where I can see this
presentation and maybe edit it,
and edit it as any other
presentation I have.
So this is super easy.
This is super smooth
for users.
This is available to everyone.
And what we're going to talk
about today is how this works.
I think the best way to start
talking about it-- and
remember, we're all
developers.
So we're going to look at the
source of the HTML page that's
generated by this document.
So let me go back to
the presentation.
If I check the source
for this document by
viewing page source--
nothing special.
This is something that
anyone can do.
There's obviously
a lot of code.
But if I search for some
specific keywords that
[INAUDIBLE], and now Gus is
going to talk about them.
For instance, I'm going to
search for itemscope.
Itemscope is a key word in the
schema.org world that we are
now going to explain.
And what we see here is that
there is a number of
properties that we've marked
that are available in this
document that say that this is
our presentation object, which
is a type we defined to
represent the presentation.
It has a title.
It has an icon.
It has a URL.
And it has an embeddable URL.
How does this work?
GUS CLASS: So if you actually
look at the schema.org content
that's marked up across this
page, what happens is when
Google tries to calculate the
way that the activity will
look when it renders inside the
Google+ stream, it tries
to retrieve these properties
from the page first.
And then it uses those as
signals, as hints to the way
that it should present
the content.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So
we've mentioned
schema.org many times.
What's schema.org?
GUS CLASS: Schema.org is just
a way of annotating various
things on the internet and
giving all the structured data
on the web kind of that
presentation in a way that it
can be consumed easily through
search engines and through
other sites consuming
that content.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So this
is independent of Google.
It's not a Google-specific
technology.
standard or any kind of thing
that is just us.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
It's not just Google.
There's a lot of other people
out there on the web
that are doing it.
And Google likes this format
because it's a very versatile
format for describing
things on the web.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And so with
this schema.org metadata, we
can mark up some specific
properties in the HTML.
And these properties are not
specifically related to the
Google structure.
So we're saying that that file,
that page represents a
presentation.
Anyone else can do that.
So we're not saying that is a
Google Docs presentation.
We're saying that that is
a presentation, and that
presentation has a specific
title, and that presentation
has a specific embedded
URL, and so on.
And then what happens is that
Google+ reads the HTML of the
page, finds those metadata,
realizes that that is a
presentation.
And so it has a specific way to
represent those data, so to
render that data.
I've shown you how you can
check these items.
And the easy way is to
view the source.
So as we did before, you can
just check the source of the
page and see there
are some data.
Obviously, there are some other
tools that can make your
life easier.
There is one which is part of
the Google Webmaster Tools.
So that is at google.com/webma
sters/tools/richsnippets.
And with this tool, you can
extract the schema.org
metadata for any given page.
Let's try again.
Let's see what happens if I open
this tool and put the URL
of my document.
I can do preview.
This tool is going to fetch
the page, extract all the
metadata that are there,
and show them to us.
So we have a preview here that
shows some of those pieces.
But we also have what we now
care most about-- is the
extracted structure data.
What it says here is that--
well, what we already saw.
This is a presentation object.
It has a specific name.
It has an icon.
It has a URL.
And it has an embed URL.
So with this tool, it's much
easier for you to understand
what Google+ will find
about your page.
Something that is interesting
here is that this is not
specific to Google+.
So we encourage people to use
schema.org metadata, not only
because if your type is
supported, it will be shown on
Google+, but also because
we use those
information in search.
So whenever you search for
something on google.com, we
crawl all the pages, we index
them, and we store the
metadata for them.
So if, for instance, it is
hard for us to generate a
snippet, a text snippet that
summarizes your page, the
schema.org metadata in that page
will help us produce a
better snippet, and so on.
And we have other kind
of information
there that we can use.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, absolutely.
And putting that schema.org
microdata content is a great
best practice because it makes
all the information on your
web page discoverable to more
people than just Google.
I mean, if anyone's programming
against kind of
parsing that data on the page,
that schema.org microdata is
just extremely useful in
understanding semantically
what the content means.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Let's
talk a bit about
security and privacy?
GUS CLASS: Oh, yeah,
absolutely.
This is kind of the first
question that I had when you
showed me this today.
If I share something on Drive,
or share something on Google+
that is on Drive, and the
content that I'm sharing on
Drive, say it's a presentation
that's only accessible to me,
what would be the experience
that the user would have when
they click on that share link?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So the
basic rule here is that
sharing a document on Google+
will not expand the
permissions on that document.
So if I share a document with
you on Google+, and you have
access to it, you will
be able to open it.
If I share a document with you,
but a document is not
shared with you on Drive, you
will not be able to open it.
Now why do we do that?
Well, the main [? use case, ?]
the main thing we want to
prevent is this.
I share a private document
to a friend of mine.
And that friend has
access to it.
Fine.
But then my friend re-shares
the post I shared with him
with someone else.
I don't want that someone
else to be
able to read my document.
So by not expanding the
[INAUDIBLE] or permissions, we
are preventing third parties
from sharing
your sensitive documents.
So we really care about your
privacy on your documents.
So we don't want that for some
reasons, any reasons, by
mistake or by malicious users,
your documents will be
readable or editable
by third parties.
If the document we shared with
you on Google+ is not
accessible to you, what you
would see is the usual request
access page.
So you will see that a document
is shared with you on
Google+, but you will not be
able to see any content.
So if you want to be able to
access it, you will have to
request permission to
the original owner.
And of course, if the original
owner grants you access, then
you will be able to
read the document.
GUS CLASS: So you're kind of
highlighting something that's
real clear here.
And it's that basically, what
you're doing is you're
sharing that link.
And it's almost no different
as though you were sharing
that link on something
other than Google+.
It's like you're sharing
it in email.
But Google is rendering and
presenting that content based
on the schema.org microdata.
And then it kind of just behaves
in a way that the user
would expect it to as though
it were working
directly from Drive.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
That's absolutely correct.
Whenever we share a document
on Google+,
we're sharing a link.
That's exactly a link like any
other link, so just a link to
something that we know--
eventually, we know that that
something is a document.
And then we know we have a
better way to present a
document to you.
But the content that is
there is just not
known in the beginning.
So we share link, it
can be a video.
Then if you can see
the video, fine.
If your link is behind, I don't
know, a firewall, you
will not be able to see it.
Same here.
If a link is to a document that
is not available to you,
then you will not be
able to read it.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Perfect.
OK, I think there's just one
extra step to discuss.
And that is, how does this
work with the API?
GUS CLASS: And so
that's actually
a really good question.
Because there's kind
of two parts to it.
There's the part where there's
the Drive API, and then
there's the Google+ API.
And so I did a little
investigation this morning,
sharing something publicly,
which was
in everyone's stream.
But what you can do is you can
still read the activity that
gets created on the stream.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: We
can show you that.
So use the APIs Explorer to get
the information about a
specific activity, given
the activity ID.
And that specific activity
had a document shared.
And so this is a request.
If you know the Google+ API,
this is very easy to
understand.
We just do a get to
the specific end
point for the activity.
And we get some metadata here.
But what?
We don't see a reference
to the document itself.
So do you want to just explain
a bit what we see here?
GUS CLASS: Sure.
So some of the things that
you're seeing currently is the
format of these activities is
that there's the activity
itself, an actor associated with
the activity, and then
attachments that are appended
onto the end of that activity.
And so the attachment of
interest is going to be the
actual share that happened
from that Drive post.
And so if you look into the
object array that's specified
in the JSON at the end of this
content here, the first one
will actually be something that
represents the post itself.
And currently, we're sending
back a self link so that if
you were using this inside of
a third party integration,
where you're reading this
activity content, you could
link back to the post
really easily.
What is interesting to me is
actually getting back to that
base URL from Drive.
Because then once you can
do that, you can start
incorporating the Drive API to
get the one true metadata from
the actual object
itself in Drive.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: That's an
important point to highlight.
So this integration
is totally new.
So we are still working on
it and we appreciate your
feedback on it.
And at the moment, the Google+
API doesn't expose any
information about the
shared document.
But we think it might be
worth considering this
addition to the API.
So we will bring this
up and see if we can
add it to the API.
But assuming we get a reference
to the document in
the API, what we would expect
is to only get an ID or a
reference to the document,
but nothing else.
Well, maybe the title or the
rest of the metadata that are
in the snippet.
But that's it.
Then we would expect developers
to use that ID
together with the Drive API to
perform activities, to perform
actions on the document
itself.
So if we add information about
a document to the Plus API,
that information should only
be used together with the
Drive API to perform
manipulation of the file content.
So don't expect, let's say,
the content of the
presentation to be available
in the Plus API.
There will be an overlap between
the Google+ API, the
Google Doc, and Google
Drive API.
And also remember that the
Google+ API asks for some
specific permissions
that do not include
reading your document.
So if an application can only
read your Google+ API, it
should not be allowed to
read your document.
If you want to do both, you will
have to request for both
permissions, and the
user will have to
specifically approve both.
Which makes sense.
And it guarantees security and
privacy for your data.
GUS CLASS: So yeah, like you
were saying, really having the
document within Drive and then
making changes to that
document also would then be
reflected in the content
that's referenced.
We want people to make all
of their reads from Drive
documents as opposed
to directly
through the Google+ API.
You avoid duplication of data.
And also, you kind of have
that definitive privacy
control that happens
at the Drive side.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So we're
going to investigate this, and
we're going to investigate
how to add these
features to the API.
And we might talk about this
in a future Google
Developers Lab event.
GUS CLASS: Yes, absolutely.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
So stay tuned for this.
We're going to announce
it on Google+.
Before we wrap up, I just wanted
to mention that we
showed a presentation.
But this integration works with
all types of documents on
Google Drive.
So you can share a text
document, you can share a
spreadsheet, you can share a
presentation, and so on.
So obviously, they will have
different renderings.
So a presentation
looks like this.
You can browse the slide.
With a spreadsheet, it obviously
looks different.
And each of them has
a specific UI.
And the last thing I want to
mention is that we added this
new feature for Google
properties right now.
So you can share Google
Docs into Google+.
But as we said, all it takes
for us to understand what a
document is, is to add some
generic metadata coming from
schema.org.
And no one prevents other
products to do the same.
So for instance, many of you
will know SlideShare.
SlideShare is a very popular
service for hosting slides.
Nothing prevents them from
adding those metadata.
And we do not render that yet,
but we are definitely thinking
about doing it for
other properties.
So we need to balance between
avoiding spam
and things like that.
We don't want anyone to add
random data there, and we then
have to be forced to capture
those data or do something to
prevent abuse.
But for instance, for important
third parties like
SlideShare or others, we can
think about extending this new
feature to support all
presentations out there, all
documents out there,
and so on.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
Yeah, you highlighted
a really good point.
With schema.org, when you have
your page marked up well,
Google can do a lot more with
that content when they have
those hints from within
your document as
to what is in there.
And so Google always tries
to calculate the
right thing to render.
And over time, these
things change.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
OK, I think that with that,
that's it for today for Google
Developers Live.
I hope to see you soon.
The Google Drive team goes
live again on Thursdays.
And we might see
you again here.
I might be joining you on the
Google+ events, right?
GUS CLASS: Absolutely.
Yeah maybe we'll have you over
on the Google+ GDL here soon.
It was a pleasure being here.
And it's exciting to hear about
all the integrations
that are happening
with Google+.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
Thank you very much.
GUS CLASS: Thanks.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]